you
hi everyone is cherry this is video 11
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and we're going to have a look
at the element of time in chess in every
chess game there is a race going on a
time race and I'm not speaking of the
time on the clocks or the time controls
but rather the time on the chess board
itself we take turns in chess and when
it's our turn we can only make one move
we know this we have exactly one unit of
time one tempo in other words there's a
time race and it begins that move won
the race is to see who can completely
mobilize their entire army first who can
better improve the overall quality of
their position now we're already
familiar with the material element in
chess and it isn't too hard a task to
keep track of who is up materialise
point wise in fact many chess playing
websites out there will provide you with
the crutch we're having an answer to
that
who's up material wise question is a
cinch off to the side they'll show you
the captured pieces and or some
combination of a little they'll show you
the numerical value that represents
material time that just like material
plays a very important role in the game
sometimes a far more important role in
the game when compared to material there
is no crutch for the time element though
you have to interpret the position and
assess the time element all on your own
and you ought to keep track of it
or at the very least have a very good
sense of who is up at any point in the
game who is up timewise so what I'm
going to share with you in this video is
a way you can keep track of time so that
by these videos and you'll always have
an answer to the question who is winning
the time race having an answer to this
question will ultimately help us
make better decisions when playing it's
not just about having an answer to that
time question who's up timewise it's
about how we can apply it how is this
useful how can we better improve as a
player by knowing this information just
bear with me here I recognize this is a
lot of me just talking right now but I
do have several examples I will show you
that shortly but there's a certain point
I need to make here just as we are
already familiar with the general
principle in relation to material it's
already been shared that when we have a
material advantage a material plus a
good general principle is to make even
exchanges to simplify the position so
that one day hopefully when we are up
upon we can simplify it all the way down
so it's King and pawn versus King and
we're already experts with how to
successfully promote that pawn similarly
once we know who is up timewise there
are general principles that will also
guide our play some strategies we can
follow when we know who is up timewise
so we're going to see how we can keep
track of it and I'll show several
examples of how we can maybe be losing
time and not even realizing it okay so
here's the first example right here and
don't pay too much attention to a blacks
doing they're doing a developing move
which is not a good developing move and
then under developing focus on what
white is doing every move thus far is
great it's getting a new piece out and
white is getting one step closer with
each move to this position right here
where the rooks are in direct connection
with one another this right here is what
many regard as being fully developed
I've referenced it as this many times
most most cases I represent or I call
direct connection between the rooks as
being fully developed I'd like to adjust
that statement a little bit I'd like to
be a little bit more exact here this
direct connection between the rooks is
an excellent reference point and it's
the one we're going to use to gauge time
okay this is an excellent start but do
know that we are not quite where we want
to be as white we're far ahead here
timewise we have it took us eight moves
to get to this point and if black is to
get their pieces out the best-case
scenario it's a it's going to take them
eight moves from this position we still
do know we still as white need to do a
couple more things as I've already
referenced in a previous video in this
series we're still seeking a pawn break
so that a file can become half opened or
opened and we also need to move the rook
to that half open or open file so we're
very close here as white no doubt about
that but do know that we're not quite
where we want to be we are not fully
mobilized as white but this is an
excellent reference point this is where
we want to be this is what we will use
to gauge who is doing better timewise as
it stands right now white is ahead by
eight tempi okay I know it's a very
exaggerated example but I just wanted to
draw some attention to having a direct
connection between the rooks it will
take black eight moves before they could
be in a similar position with their
Brooks in direct contact with one
another okay let's have a look at an
example here that's something I found
interesting many players do this many of
these examples by the way are pulled
from standard chess games played so
doing some research online and I found
interesting examples for time here ways
that we can be losing time so far not
too bad in fact let me just back up
it may help when playing to categorize
your moves and your opponent's moves as
a developing or B non developing if you
don't like those words you could also
view it as productive or unproductive
the first move here d4 is a good one
I'll just stick with the move developing
it's a developing move it's opening a
door for the bishop this is a great
start
black on the other hand it's not opening
a door for the bishop with this pawn
move but it does influence the center of
the board it's striking it a pawn that's
in the center so there is some value to
them okay this is still a fine move
white develops that's good
black eliminates that central pawn okay
white is recapturing black is getting on
with a developing move another
developing move because it frees the
bishop so there's now a door open for
the white bishop there's a door open for
the black Bishop e5 is developing it
opens the door for the dark square
bishop so far so good night f3 you have
to react d6 a new door for the bishop
and now the move b3 I have a problem
with this move the move b3 I interpret
as follows i I see this as white saying
you know what the one door that's open
for my bishop isn't good enough
I don't like it enough to go out that
door I'm going to open up a new door I'm
going to spend one of my moves and open
up a new door because I think my bishop
will be better placed here I don't like
the move there's one door already open I
don't think there's enough justification
here for white to invest a move to
deploy the bishop through a different
door okay a better move is Knight c3 or
Bishop c4 and then getting on with
castles what's wrong with Bishop e3 or
Bishop g5 one day pinning the knight
this is a waste of time and I see it
quite often it's for some reason it's
it's not good enough to have just one
door open for the bishop he only needs
one door you just picture the bishop in
a house right
there's a house bishop in it in the
house has two doors both are currently
closed how does the bishop get out of
the house he opens one door and goes
through he doesn't open two doors and
then picks one to go out one door and he
goes through it okay this is a waste of
time and I see it quite often okay maybe
you can relate to it if that's the case
fix it save yourself your time this is a
waste of time you don't need to do this
this is this is a step in the direction
of wasting time let's have a look at
another example here already so far so
good developing great the Bishop's ready
to come out you six developing the
bishops ready to come out NIDA three
another developing move Bishop c5
another developing move but I have a
problem with this one can you identify
what the problem is here's the problem
what's white going to do d4 what just
happened here white developed right
opened a new door for the bishop and did
so with an attack against an already
developed piece so what does this mean
for black it means that he should be
reacting he has to move this developed
piece right it's black smooth he would
like to get a new piece involved but
because he played Bishop c5 d four hits
and he has to move again so black is by
playing Bishop c5 helping white to
accentuate his development he's speeding
up White's
task of fully mobilizing the pieces okay
let's take just a few more moves suppose
Bishop check what's white doing
developing and blocking what's black
doing
moving and already developed peace again
what's white doing developing let's just
pause for a moment how do we stand
timewise who's winning the time race
here if we look on the white side Bishop
needs to move knight needs to move the
King needs to Castle before the rooks
are in direct connection white needs
three moves before they are fully or
excuse me not fully developed but three
moves before there's a direct connection
between the rooks black on the other
hand how many moves are needed a knight
move King ass to Castle that's to the
Queen us to move three the knight has to
move for a door one door needs to be
opened for the bishop that's five
the bishop needs to move six it's a time
plus is in favor of white let's move
forward just a little bit knowing that
we have this time edge these last few
moves are all developing moves for both
sides a door is open developing
developing developing what do we do when
we have a time edge what is a good
general principle to follow when we have
a time advantage in this position white
already has this direct connection
between the rooks black still needs a
knight move a queen move and well one of
the another piece has to move in then
the Queen so there's a time advantage
here for white what's a good general
principle when you have a time advantage
you should seek pawn exchanges the move
d5 is an excellent way to do that
engaging with the pawns why would you
want to do this what's the big idea here
one thing I want to make clear I don't
want you to memorize here you are up
material-wise me just saying to you well
when you're up material why excuse me
when you're up timewise make pawn
exchanges open the position
are you are you satisfied with that
answer you shouldn't be because I have
not yet provided any reasons for why you
should do that the those are the
important questions having the answers
to those why questions those critical
thinking questions are what is important
it's that's what's going to take you
from simply memorizing to understanding
why we do this why should we be seeking
pun exchanges let's have a very close
look at why this is the case why should
we open the position when we have an
edge when we have an advantage timewise
let's see pawn exchanges what will
result with this type of capture the
opening up of a file these already
developed these more developed pieces
that we have are now becoming optimized
the possibilities that are now present
for our pieces are becoming greater note
notice the possibilities now for the
Queen and the rook if as we look at it
right now they stopped cold along the D
file as far as the d3 square if the D
pawn is no longer around now look at the
potential for both Queen and rook d3 d4
d5 d6 d7 okay
creating pawn exchanges will open files
will open diagonals will help to
optimize the pieces that we already have
developed this is why we should seek
pawn exchanges and welcome the opening
up of the position the pawn captures are
what we are welcome to when we have that
time edge it mobilizes their pieces we
have more possibilities and the more
possibilities we have the better okay
that's really as far as I want to take
it here this time edge is still present
and there's a lot of pressure against
the black position the D pawn the rook
or hit but just want to emphasize we're
up timewise a good
general principle is to seek on
exchanges in let's look at the flip side
of things here too should it be the case
where you're down timewise are you going
to be so welcome to having the position
open up no so should a decision come
about where you can make upon capture or
a pawn advance to close the position
maybe you should be looking to close the
position if you're down timewise okay so
it works both ways here it's not just
about okay you have a time advantage
open the position let's look at the flip
side of things if you're down timewise
hang on I probably want to keep the
position closed okay let's have a look
at another example here give me a moment
I bring it up there we go
developing move developing move creating
a pawn duo striking at the center it
doesn't help out one of the bishops with
this move but it's still a fine move
it's contributing to the center of the
board and having an influence on the
pawn structure in the center just as a
rough guide moving making about let's
say three pawn moves in the early stage
of the game this is probably a good
number of pawn moves going beyond that
well you better have some pretty good
justification for it but just giving you
a rough feel three pawn moves is usually
sufficient maybe even a fourth with the
capture and such but just giving you a
ballpark figure in order to be fully
mobilized for those that are more on the
map you side I know that's pretty much
my mentality to try and look at the
chessboard and you use you some logic
wherever I can just giving you as a
rough guide approximately twelve moves
and you should be really really close
really really close to having your
entire army mobilize I'm not talking
right now just about that direct
connection between the rooks I'm talking
about going beyond that having the pawn
break in or I should say creating the
pond tension as white is doing at this
very early moment creating the pond
tension at some point making a capture
and then making use
of that open file so roughly 12 moves to
get that entire army 12 Tempe to get
your entire army mobilized okay so let's
move forward here still identifying
certain moves is developing non
developing okay this has it's a
productive move it's reinforcing the
central point nine f3 Knight f6 and
moving forward a little bit so far so
good
developing for both sides Knight there
b3 preparing Bishop here the this by the
way here's another point you know I was
drawing emphasis very early on to well
there's already a door open here what in
the world are you doing wasting some
time earlier I said you know is why not
open up one door and just go out it this
is a different story right here as why
if the bishop is just playing to d2 it's
kind of a half developing move it's off
the back rank but it really isn't doing
much in this particular case it is
worthwhile investing this tempo to
deploy the bishop here it's worth the
time to do that in this case here I see
moves like this played you know quite
often I would say in lower level games
they're familiar with getting the pieces
off the back rank but sometimes these
half developing moves are played and
it's just not a product in the end it
isn't a productive piece in this
particular case it's good to invest an
additional tempo and get the bishop on
the longest diagonal and the chessboard
okay in that earlier position the bishop
had other options it could have played
to e3 or g5 which were excellent choice
is not the case here
okay so h6 Bishop VIII to this by the
way is not a developing move but ok
sometimes the King would like to go here
later but this is the point that I would
like to bring your attention to it's
blacks move here
there and black now plays the move Queen
to c7 how do you feel about that move
how would you identify how would you
describe that move is it a developing
move is it a non developing move if
you'd like to pause the video and try
and work that one out on your own feel
free to do that I'm just going to dive
right into the explanation Queen c7
developing or not developing what do you
think the answer it's a developing move
but it's a developing move that will
eventually backfire on black I want you
to notice something here and this will
this will draw your attention to
anticipating certain structural changes
within a chess game certain pawn
captures as it stands right now notice
that there is tension on the d5 pawn
there's an attacker and there's a
defender and should white choose to do
so he can he or she can capture on the
d5 square and after the smoke clears
whether it's pawn takes right away or
Knight takes let's just say Knight takes
after the smoke clears what ends up
happening when pawns make captures
something changes files change
something's changed with the C file it's
now opened and how comfortable do you
think the Queen is on this now
completely open file when there are
still both rooks on board the answer not
comfortable at all soon white will be
able to make a move like this row to c1
gaining a move against the Queen
developing the rook to an open file and
now this already developed piece has to
do what move again the black is wasting
time by playing the move Queen to c7 on
the surface it appears that the Queen is
developed because she's off the back
rank but she will have to lose time
black will have to lose time
if white goes in for this exchange on
this Square after rook here even though
there's a knight in the way there's
already the threat to move the knight
with the discovered attack against the
Queen she does not stand well on this c7
square
they're the c-file this is this takes
some practice but recognizing certain
pond tension like this having an
attacker and offender viewing this
position here with these prawns viewing
it as if they are both no longer they're
looking at the attacker and the defender
viewing it as you know then vanishing
here the c-file can open up in a blink
the Queen does not sit well here so this
takes a little bit more work to view it
like this but this is another way that
you can be losing time okay it's a
little bit more involved but it's
important to recognize these finer
points here the small small ways you may
be losing time and time will add up okay
so let's dive right into another example
here here we go developing striking at
the center okay it's not developing but
this is quite often a pond that can
cause the opponent some problems notice
it does take away a square from that
Queen Knight could be quite
uncomfortable having a pond in your
position and that's what black is having
to now work around okay II 6 opens the
door for the Bishop c4 it reinforces
this pawn developing developing
developing here's a door for the bishop
another developing move the bishops
ready to come out so not too bad
and this is where I have a problem
similar to one of the first examples I
shared with you we have the move b6
what's going on here this this diagonal
is not good enough this pawn could make
a capture and the bishop can make use of
g4 at some point this is a waste of time
and I'd like to go one step further with
this pawn configuration deploying the
bishop here is equivalent to having the
bishop one day simply bite on a rock
okay
this pawn is going nowhere a bishop on
b7
is doesn't even have let's let's fast
forward a little bit actually not not
not too fast this Bishop b7 move a
bishop on the b7 square isn't even
threatening to enter the white position
at all it's not even observing any
square on White's part it's of no bother
to white if it's staring right at the d5
pawn which is a an excellent strong
point in the white position now what
follows is another it's another move
that I have a problem with timewise
Knight b5 what are you doing here you're
moving in already developed piece you've
gotten away as what you've gotten away
from what it is you ought to be doing in
a chess game fully mobilizing your
pieces and also let me point this out
there are going to be times in a chess
game where your opponent will do
something that is equivalent to maybe I
don't know waving a stick right in front
of your face trying to distract you okay
don't be distracted know what it is you
ought to be doing in a chess game and do
it you're supposed to be getting all of
your pieces out and do just that Knight
b5 I'm not sure what the story is with
this move what's wrong with the Knight
f3 Bishop d3 the bishop coming out this
is moving an already developed piece
again it's a waste of time and I don't
know what is even threatening this this
Knight you you really want to if you're
going to be advancing like this is why
you really should have more pieces
involved this Knight is just going into
no-man's land if the black pieces
carried some emotion and they were to
speak it I mean they're laughing right
now I mean what do you think you're
doing here your apps you're no threat to
me whatsoever in fact what happened was
a6 he got kicked and he went right back
is there way you can now make use of
having the pawn on a6 when compared to
a7 no okay that was a complete waste of
time
okay moving forward that's a developing
move another developing move developing
but biting on a rock and now pawn takes
so this is a one other point in the last
point from this
example here what did white just do he
made this pond capture so pun captures
the interesting interesting moment right
here white needs to recognize that for
as long as they maintain this pawn on d5
the bishop is a dead piece he's just
staring it upon that is really really
well
reinforced I can't get more reinforced
pawn wise than this so this pond should
be maintained he is excellent in fact if
we look from a time standpoint how much
time was invested with this deep on how
many moves
how many Tempe were spent in order to
get the pawn to d5 well let's see one
two two Tempe to get to that point and
now what does white do all that time and
effort I know it's just two moves but
all that time and effort to get to d5
and what did white do he threw it all
away he's like I don't you know what I
don't want to have my pawn on d5 anymore
that was an excellent pun you're getting
rid of you may want to view it as
exchanging off a fifth rank pump White's
fifth rank pawn for blacks second rank
pawn okay this is an excellent pond
right here right after this capture chop
chop it is as if the d5 pond was
exchanged for the f7 pond this was a
really strong pawn on d5 and it was
given away some time was lost here
playing d4 d5 and then making another
pawn move capturing it is not time
well-spent
there are more efficient ways to play
this position now Knight f3 perfectly a
perfect move to play Bishop e7 is a
follow up okay getting all of your
pieces out is the name of the game and
in these examples we're not even ten
moves into the game and there are
already these adjustments that could be
made these short or not short but these
minor improvements they again they add
up these little ways you could be losing
time can add up all right
let's move forward here look at another
example about five more examples to go
through here's another one right here
okay developing developing developing
and Knight to e7 if we're just to pause
right here I know it's very early about
who's winning the time race here okay
white to be expected he has two moves in
black has one yeah how many do we need
one two three four a door has to open
five six moves and black still need
seven okay
after blacks next move ninety-seven does
he still need you know does he need six
moves or seven moves where does black
stand in fact right now where does black
stand timewise he stops to move the
knight Bishop King Queen Knight a door
has to be open for the bishop one a one
of these two right here so one two three
four five six with the pawn move and
then seven after ninety-seven you would
think it's now six but it's still seven
why the bishop has to move still and how
is he getting out he just blocked him in
this was his door to come out and now
the Knights in the way so in order to
complete King side development black has
to open it has to go about how opening a
new door and playing to g7 or moving the
knight again and then moving the bishop
so this is not a developing move it may
appear on the surface that it's a
developing move but it's not it's
getting in the way of blacks development
it would be a far different story if the
bishop was already out and then the
knight played here ok different story
not the case though black is wasting
time with a move like this just as was
highlighted opening up a second door to
get the bishop out what about playing
your knight to a position and the bishop
can now no longer move on and already
open door out of an outer out of an
already opened door this is not
productive this is
again what one might think is developing
but it is not okay it's it's getting in
the way black is no better off having
the night on e7 in this position
what's wrong with Knight to f6 okay or
playing playing here 97 is not good this
is not helping blacks development let's
have a look at another one here give me
a moment there we go
okay d4 d5 c4 e6 so far so good right
developing developing forming a pawn duo
striking at the center not bad it's good
g6 opens the door for this guy Knight c3
is developing developing developing
developing developing developing
developing this is another case where
it's actually a good one it could be a
little bit tricky I know opening up two
doors for the bishop in some situations
I'm saying it's not a good it's not
worthwhile to open up a new door spend a
time spend a tempo to get the bishop on
a different diagonal in this particular
case it is playing the bishop here is
one of those half developing moves it is
better placed on this square so this is
time well spent to play b6 and get the
bishop on this square also I mean if we
have a look at what blacks going to do
with the knight I mean if he goes here
while he's getting in the Bishop's way
this is actually a good square for the
knight because when compared to c6
I've already referenced that when the D
pawns are in play like this when the D
pawns are on these fourth ranks what
does that C pawn like to do he likes to
move whether it be one or two squares
forward he likes to have the option to
move so obstructing this guy with the
knight not really a good idea
in fact if that did happen where does
the Queen eventually go was the bishop
go there's a little bit of a space
disadvantage for black here tough to
find squares for the piece
is if if the night played here and we
had something like this with the Queen
stepping up and then the bishop playing
here well look at how cluttered this is
here in fact c5 already would win the
Queen
the short story here is that this is a
justified second door to open for the
Bishop b6 is fine
a3 it's not a developing move but I just
wanted to play this to emphasize the
following point we now have the move by
black and D take C before I put this
move on the board here let's take stock
of where we stand
timewise for each side let's not lose
sight of who is winning the time race so
let's do a quick count here how are
things looking on the white side how
many moves before white is before white
has that direct connection between the
rooks a bishop needs to move that's one
the King needs to Castle that's two the
Queen needs to move three three moves
for white what about black black still
needs let's just say let's just say like
this black still needs to address the
knight Bishop and Queen still three
pieces to get out okay it's blacks move
in this position and black captures on
c4 what does white do and this move by
the way how might you describe it it's a
move that breaks up a pawn duo okay it's
an it's not a developing move but it
does address the center of the board the
pawn structure in some way this capture
so let's just say D take C here and now
what is white do white recaptures and
now how do we stand timewise well white
is one step closer to having that direct
connection between the rooks in fact
white now only needs two moves before
there's that direct connection between
the rooks black on the other hand well
it's the same story
Knight bishop in Queens still have to do
something
productive let's backtrack for a moment
here I'd like to emphasize drawing your
attention right now to the timing of
certain moves when certain moves are
played can influence the the time
element that's probably a better way to
state it like that but the let's just
say the moment at which you make certain
moves has an influence on the time
element black is capturing this pun at a
moment when the bishop has not yet moved
if we compare this with the following
suppose instead of capturing at this
moment here supposed black plays Bishop
b7 and after white says well I want to
get castled so I need to move my bishop
and plays Bishop to d3 how about now how
about black now captures on c4 chop-chop
how are things looking in this position
still two moves for white but black on
the other hand only has two pieces they
need to get Duke to get out in order to
do something productive
some time was saved there or I should
say some time was lost by white due to
blacks patience with capturing on the c4
square black by playing Bishop b7 which
is an excellent move black first waits
for this bishop to make make one move
black wants white to invest one tempo
with the bishop move before black
captures on the c4 square so what's
really happening with this last
variation I'm showing you is that the
bishop took two moves to get to the c-4
square plate to d3 and then C 4 it took
2 moves in other words for white to
capture the pawn on c4 instead of one
move ok so this is a finer little point
with regard to having some patience and
keeping what we call pawn
mention in the position doing being
aware of these things are there's again
it's adding up these these little timing
details are going to have an influence
on who's better developed who's closer
to having their pieces fully mobilized
okay having some patience not yet
capturing playing Bishop b7 and only
capturing on this square after the
bishop has moved why had to waste some
time took two moves to get to the c-4
square instead of just a point A to
point B capture one move capture okay
let's have a look at just a few more
examples here there we go
a developing move another developing
move development development D for
developing move forming a pawn duo what
is black do he breaks up the pawn duo
that's good Knight recaptures gotta get
that material back and now black
captures the knight that's the first non
developing move
he's already developed and he's moving
again this is a mistake it's not a it's
not one that's showing up it's not a
material material mistake it's a time
mistake it's blacks move well a new
piece has to come out about Bishop c5
Knight f6 there is nothing wrong with
these moves black instead made an on
developing move and what does white do
of course recaptures and develops white
is already winning the time race white
just by the rules of the chess game
right
white moves first White's going to have
that time edge White's now up some time
here one two three a king move for black
needs one two three one pawn move four
five six down to where light is up two
moves here alright let's move forward
just a little bit more d6 it's
developing okay bishops ready to come
out developing
a six non developing let me again
emphasize do not be distracted by your
opponent's moves do not be distracted
from developing your entire army after a
six is played white plays the move a
four that's not developing I guess light
didn't want the move b5 to be played
bring b5 on if I'm playing the white
side if you want to play b5 great you
know what's going to happen I'm going to
I'm going to laugh a little bit I'm
going to say well it's another another
non developing move black is really
excited apparently about opening up a
new door for that Bishop because this
one here isn't good enough this is a
waste of time white is being distracted
white is distracted here and is not
getting on with developing what white
should be playing Bishop c4 Bishop f4
new pieces out again do not get
distracted focus on what it is you ought
to do in a chess game develop develop
develop focus on that time element a4
was played let's go a little bit further
c5 non developing it attacks the Queen
it creates weaknesses something that
will be touched on a little bit more
there'll be a big focus on that topic
but okay non developing c5 the Queen
goes back home it's it's an under
developing move but I could see why you
would want to do that
playing here or here gets in one of the
two bishops you know gets in the way of
one of those guys so okay Queen d1 it's
fine
developing developing okay we're back on
track we're getting some developing
moves in g6 another one of those moves
opens up a second door for the bishop
some time is being wasted here castles
Bishop here how we looking two moves
away to be have that direct connection
between the rooks for white how many
moves for black a bishop move a King
move a Queen move okay so
not too bad I know I'm looking at the
numbers for each side like okay white
needs this number of moves before
there's the direct connection between
the rooks black needs this number of
moves but the main focus should really
be on the difference between those two
numbers is there a difference at all and
if there is how can we how can we apply
it should we be opening the position or
not okay it's the difference between
both sides
the time factor for each side is the
difference between those numbers that
should really be our focus okay so
really not much of a time difference in
this one but this is where white now
goes astray you ready f4 what's this an
on developing move yes it forms a pandu
oh but what's wrong with bringing a new
piece out what's wrong with Bishop f4
Bishop f4 is an instance of development
with an attack and what are you doing
about your d6 pawn really nothing you
can't save him here's one way you could
defend under developing guess what
happens next white is one move away from
being fully developed and black is one
two three four let's open the position
up how would you do that
'if I've create pawn exchanges open up
files pawn takes there's already tactics
Bishop sweeps in the King is running for
his life and this Knight is under fire
the rooks are ready cause the king of
headache things can crumble in a blink
okay all white needs to do was continue
to develop get all the pieces out Bishop
f4 focus on that time element get every
piece working light was not yet fully
mobilized the bishop needs to come out
the Queen needs to come out here's a
wonderful square for the rook a
half-open file
doing a move as simple as Bishop f4 in
black is in a very very difficult
position oh look I would go as far as
saying a losing position dropping upon
and just no good no good here 14 block
okay so have a look at just a couple
more examples in fact as a close well
have a look at a very famous game here's
the last example here so so far so good
both sides developing developing
developing if no problems with any of
these this is an on developing move a
six there this might be the idea here to
play b5 there may be some point to it
but as we'll see with blacks next move
in the end there's no point to it after
Bishop c4 we have that pawn move again
so that's a clear a waste of time so
white is up timewise every move White
has been playing is a developing move ok
black is back on track knight c6 Queen
d2 developing Bishop g7 developing
castles ok we have that direct
connection white is already there black
needs what King move Bishop move Queen
move mmm yeah so he's behind three Tempe
and what does black do next
be five there's a problem with that move
isn't there you see the problem here
what's wrong with the e5 move black is
down timewise and is apparently welcome
to upon exchange really the position
wants to Oh black is welcome to the
opening up of the position when they're
behind time wise this is a terrible move
but as white how might you react to such
a move is an important question
I see many players do the following d5
and I'm not quite sure why I move like
d5 is played I'm going to take some
guesses here d5 I think might be played
for the following reasons one I think
many players like to have one of their
pawns and it's attack a piece of greater
value attack and Knight Bishop Queen
rook okay they'd like to have that
happen but I wonder if some other
thought might be you know maybe one
other reason why white might want to
play them of d5 is maybe because they
think oh well you know it's not only
attacking the knight but it's one step
closer to queening I'm just speculating
here I'm just trying to
provide reasons for maybe why a move
like d5 is played I think the primary
one however is well I you know I get to
advance one of my pawns in my opponent's
position I get to attack their knight
but it's it's neglecting this element of
time d5 is ignoring this idea that when
you have a time advantage you should
seek pawn exchanges whatwhat does D
takes e5 do it opens up the D file the
Queen because look at all the different
possibilities the Queen has right after
after this capture d4 d5 d6 moreover
when the pawn is on d5 look at the
squares it takes away from the bishop
from the knight it diminishes the bishop
and knights mobility this is not a good
move to close the position when you're
up timewise no good it's against the
general principle maybe there's some
exceptions to the junta mcc's epson's
but again a general principle open up
the position when you have that time
edge capturing on e5 is best in fact it
will net some material
chop-chop-chop-chop again King is on
castle there goes upon soon a rook is
going to develop and attack the King
this is bad news for team black clearly
the main point when you're up material
here you should seek pawn exchanges okay
as black why you playing e5 you should
not be welcome to pawn exchanges okay
now as a close I'd like to share with
you a very famous game by uh Paul Morphy
ah who understood time better than any
other player in his time he had a better
sense of the element of time and his
opponents were not quite up to speed
with the element of time they were more
focused on material and
this allowed many amazing games by Paul
Morphy this is a game Paul Morphy was
playing on the white pieces versus Duke
Carl and there's a combination he was
playing against two guys do Carl and
count
ice ice ward from 1858 Paris France
let's have a look at this game because
I'm not quite finished with this general
principle about opening the position
when you're up timewise there's also
another one that I want you to be very
familiar with okay
let's have a look efore development
development so far so good
d6 defends opens up a new door d4 good
move developing Bishop g4 it's
developing however after D takes e Oh
what does black do black captures so
this last move is the first non
developing move and already developed
piece is capturing the night you might
view it as capturing a pinned piece
normally should shy away from capturing
a pinned piece it's not harmful in any
way but black is basically doing this
because if captures there now would
follow Queen takes Queen King takes
Queen and then the win of a pawn so in
order to in order to avoid the loss of
upon because of blacks decision in fact
to play Bishop g4 after takes here black
has to waste some time capture the night
after the recapture we have this
recapture already White has a time
advantage I know in many of the examples
I showed there was a time advantage of
3/4 in this particular one it's not as
great a time advantage but notice we
already have
in open position we already have we
don't need a pawn break it's already
we're already there the position is what
we might call half opened so if it's
already open especially if it's already
open there should there should already
be a great emphasis on development but
in positions that are open there you
should really really focus it's it's
that much more important to focus on
getting your entire army involved okay
let's get some more moves in here we
have Bishop c4 developing actually
threatening mate on f7 Knight f6 that's
a developing move that addresses the
threat on f7 that's saying it is best
but it's already even even though
there's a slight edge timewise for white
so it's already uncomfortable that's one
way to view it is if you have a slight
edge timewise if you can start
generating threats with these further
advanced pieces that you have this
further advanced army that you have
deployed you can start dictating play
you could starting to touch right now on
this the term initiative you could start
to dictate play you could be the boxer
who's throwing the punches and it could
be your opponent who's having to duck
and hopefully avoid getting punched you
can start to dictate play and give
direction and make accomplishing what
well you get you can make it difficult
for black to continue with completing
his own development okay this is
highlighted in a great way the Queen b3
is not bringing a new piece into the
game but notice the great influence it
has it's pinpointing f7 and b7 both very
weak points
Queenie seven white could if he wants go
ahead and capture on b7 Queen e7 defends
against f7 Queen B
was not played this is this would be a
fine move the reason it wasn't played
because Queen before and then the
Queen's are exchanged and this
alleviates some of the pressure off of
black getting the Queen's exchanged
instead white gets a new piece out
continues to develop Knight c3 what does
black do it's difficult
notice this Queen e7 move is it was
defending f7 but it's getting in the way
of smooth of development the door that
was open for the bishop it still can't
come out there's a piece in its way c6
Black has to now react to possibilities
of a knight jumping into the d5 square
so it's now covered a new pieces out
Bishop g5 pinning the knight to the
Queen White is one move away from being
fully or excuse me having the direct
connection between the rooks we have now
the move b5 black on the other hand
needs some of the Queen the bishop the
knight and then the King he's four moves
back white is just one move away and
also one move away from doing - very
good things note there is queenside
castle in this particular case queenside
castle in this game in this position
would accomplish two things King safety
and rook activity you don't always get
that but the D file is completely open
if you can Castle queenside and have a
completely open D file or maybe a
half-open file with a a target like a
weak pawn of blacks on the D file that
might be worth a good look castling a
queen side doing two two very good
things with your one move okay as the
follow up black plays b5 and this is the
other thing I wanted to highlight here
I've already shared that when you have a
time advantage seeking
exchanges opening up the position is
very good here's another thing that you
have in your back pocket when you have
that time advantage know this the number
of combinations the number of tactical
sequences that are available to you in a
chess game are increased you have more
pieces out it stands to reason you have
more possibilities you more move
combinations are available in the in
this position for white because of his
lead time wise sacrifices investing some
material in other words in order to
advance your side of the board in order
to move your pieces forward investing
some material and going in for an attack
these possibilities are increased when
you have that time advantage white
invest some material with his next move
sacrificing his knight moving forward
dictating play throwing a check at the
black King Knight d7 queenside castle
the rook already is there and rook here
notice the King he's caught in the
middle more sacrifices are now present
rook takes rook takes last piece
involved bishop Queen Bishop rook King
stuck in the middle Bishop not playing
rook sad rook in the corner Knight
pinned rook pinned is there anything
good on the black side know what stride
is a queen exchange but the game
finishes off beautifully with Bishop
takes rook Knight takes bishop Queen b8
offering up the Queen she has to be
taken after Knight takes Queen rook d8
and that's me so it's a really nice game
clearly it's a very well known game here
by Paul Morphy but the main focus here
is the element of time here putting it
to good use being familiar with the
general principles of opening up the
position when you have that time
advantage knowing that the tactical your
tactical prospects these come move
sequences combinations are increased as
you have a time advantage when we look
at it on the flip side of things if
you're down timewise if you're still
struggling to catch up timewise she
really shouldn't be so welcome to having
a position open up for your opponent's
further advanced army your further there
further developed pieces so keep these
things in mind it's not just about
having an answer to who is up timewise
who's winning the race and you know
that's as far as we go with it we want
to know how to apply it so hopefully
I've helped to illuminate this idea in
the chess game this idea of the the time
element in chess so what I would really
like to do like you to do I mean if
you're I imagine if you're watching this
video you're really looking to improve
your game and so I think making a
conscious effort in every game you play
to pay attention to this time element
with each move you're considering simply
ask of yourself is the move I'm
considering developing or productive and
when your opponent makes a move ask is
my opponent's is my opponent's move
developing or productive don't allow
yourself we've seen examples of this
don't allow yourself to be distracted by
your opponent's moves to the point where
you begin to make non developing
unproductive moves this is going to
happen it takes some discipline on your
part
understanding the element of time and
applying it to your play will require
your discipline but in the end remaining
focused on this time element in the game
it will improve your play
so I think I've covered everything I
wanted to cover in this one I'll close
with how I usually close it that's all
for this video as usual I hope you got
something out of it and we'll see what's
in store
in video 12 so that's all for now take
care bye